hello and welcome to zero playing our
seed or off isn't this is the guy and oh
I thought is the high place Old in your
auditor and probably not I don't have a
good score against the sky minus one
that's still have not yet learnt this
line properly yeah so we'll see what
happens this however looks kind of
familiar like a headed earlier on the
bottom so the earlier game anyway I
think I should be all right here h5 he
goes g5 it seems let's put this here I
195 mmm yeah why don't I just go to e2
nobody knows after you too but it's just
a lot better of course and she has given
up like control over f/4g 5 and so on
but now that's Knight f3 and night x SI
form and nonsense but nonsensical play
should just think okay
yeah 93 what else
and check ok
Jim q only one red stuff he tries to
play with be five I guess I'm just
firing now here I don't care anymore
after this nonsense move Bishop c2 let's
just see if I can irritate them here f1
Knight takes e4 maybe bishops you too
great stuff
okay we'll see what happens he might win
material which as I said I don't care
anymore this one oh cool
Wow
okay 91 Queen g-forces this is
reasonably unclear and rook takes you
four is a is a threat okay so he's going
for it one problem is he has this e to
check stuff which is quite annoying
Queen f 5m doesn't threaten that much
Jack you start with the chick
and Queen f5 he takes be too
unfortunately so yeah this is all a big
load of mumbo jumbo it doesn't do
anything
no it treats the Queen okay white person
you have to apologize for a super awful
game probably I shouldn't should stop
this plane session it's just too hot I
cannot focus at all Bishop c2 is
completely idiotic just go here and why
this better and why it's white better
because this is a dead bishop and even
put this on the board okay but his King
side is bad I have ideas here all kinds
of ideas like blech just has a bad
position here I can cast long this is
all covered you should see two in
comparison it's just to leave your tech
now I have to have to play this and I'm
just bad yeah I'm just losing prowling
very very bad plane gadget ride for
something crazy but this is strong root
you one takes takes and black wins he's
a hookup it just is drugged you cannot
play with the King 1d one and all this
all these badly placed pieces yeah a
really bad game but I really don't feel
like not uploading those crap games
because they are part of it yes
sometimes you just just don't function
very well yeah if those off days center
yeah Bishop c2 blah very very bad okay
anyway I hope you still yeah I'm still
kind of okay after watching the
stackable came thanks for watching